so the next wife in sheep's clothing
that I see is women that put sexuality
above their children these women care
about getting sexual attention and
validation from men more than they care
about their children because they don't
stop to consider their children's
feelings from their mom posting thirst
traps on the internet many of these
women will have only fans many of these
women will chase after athletes actors
and entertainers to be their stepdaddy
for a lifetime these women will have
random men in and out of the house
constantly with no regard for the safety
of their children the most likely person
to abuse a child is actually the
stepfather but these mothers do not care
because what they care about is getting
sexual attention and gratification from
Men